[Musik] hallo zusammen wir machen heute vier
genial und einfache dressing-rezepte ich finde
gerade bei warmem Wetter aber auch bei kaltem
eigentlich immer braucht man Rezept Alternativen
zu Dressings und so dass man halt nicht immer
das gleiche macht ich starte jetzt direkt mit
dem Classic Dressing aber wirklich total klassisch
einfach aber auch sehr sehr lecker dafür starten
wir mit einer Base aus Olivenöl da bitte gutes
kaltgepresstes Olivenöl verwenden nativ extra
und da macht halt wirklich aus dass der Grund
Geschmack einfach schon lecker ist ne so und ähm
ich mache noch ein bisschen mehr rein ich mache
das immer nach Gefühl aber für euch schreibe ich
die ganz genau Mengenangaben hier unten in die
Videobeschreibung dann könnt ihr euch das einfach
aufklappen screenshotten und einkaufen gehen
wobei die meisten Zutaten müsste der eigentlich
zu Hause haben so ein Spritzer Zitronensaft kommt
jetzt noch rein nicht zu viel sonst zu sauer
ja das reicht mir schon dann für die Würze
Salz und Pfeffer mehr braucht es nicht bei
diesem Dressing so ein bisschen
Säure kommt noch durch Apfelessig
wir haben ja schon die Zitrone drin
daher hier auch nur ein bisschen reintun
gerade so ein paar Tropfen und ganz zum Schluss
kommt Senf mit rein und das war es schon das ganze
verrührt ihr dann und dann ist unser klassisches
Dressing auch schon fertig ich bin kein senfan
aber trotzdem macht das was mit dem Geschmack
also Senf pur würde ich niemals essen aber in
dem Dressing tut es wirklich was es soll und
schmeckt sehr lecker [Musik] wichtigste Zutat
vergessen und zwar die Knoblauchzehe ich brauche
dich das gar nicht schälen ich kann das auch so
das wissen die wenigstens tatsächlich ihr könnt
das einfach so in unsere Knoblauchpresse reingeben
und die Schale fängt sie dann automatisch aus
also wenn ein Date hat würde ich jetzt obwohl
steht dazu ganz ehrlich ich finde nicht dass
man sich verstecken muss so Knoblauch gehört auf
jeden Fall mit rein so und jetzt ist das Dressing
fertig und wir gehen über zu Dressing Nummer zwei
so Dressing Nummer 2 ist French Dressing auf
Basis von Joghurt ich nehme gerne 3,5%igen ich
finde der 1,5 prozentige ist ein bisschen
zu flüssig der 10 prozentige ist mir dann
allerdings wieder zu fettig also ihr könnt aber
eigentlich nehmen was ihr möchtet oder was hier
gerade da habt da kommt jetzt rein Tomatenmark
und auch wieder sind wie gesagt ich bin ein Fan
aber im Dressing tut er schon Wasser soll
also habe ich eigentlich nur Senf immer da
für meine Salatdressings so da kommen jetzt
noch Salz und Zucker rein ja richtig gehört
zucker macht einfach was mit dem Geschmack
macht den Geschmack rund der hat das bestimmt
schon mal gehört der herzhaften Gerichten immer
ein bisschen Zucker rein und bei süßen Rezepten
immer ein bisschen Salz ich habe jetzt noch
tiefkühlkräuter und zwar habe ich hier dill
und Petersilie ihr könnt aber auch andere Kräuter
nehmen das war voll entspannt je nachdem was ihr
da habt könnt ihr das ganz einfach austauschen
und jetzt fehlt nur noch ein bisschen frischer
Pfeffer und ein Schuss Essig und dann verrührt ihr
das und dann ist das Dressing auch schon fertig
[Musik] so Rezept Nummer drei da gibt es etwas
türkisches und zwar mit Granatapfelsirup ich
glaube das kennen auch die meisten aus dem
türkischen Restaurants oder generell Türken
unter sich aber auch in der generellen
orientalischen Küche in der arabischen
also es ist total weit verbreitet hier nehme
ich einfach nur Olivenöl also gutes Olivenöl
habe ich Granatapfelsirup das ist einfach nur
Granatapfelsirup ohne irgendwelche Zuckerzusätze
etc und da gibt's echt Unterschiede auf dem Markt
ich verlinke euch meins mal in die Infobox und da
kommt jetzt nur noch Salz rein und dadurch dass
es ein säuerliches Dressing also geschmacklich
für alle die in Salat säuerlich mögen perfekt und
da könnt ihr dann noch zu macht drauf geben zu
Markus essigbaumgewürzt hat man ja schon vom Namen
Essig ist ja auch immer ein bisschen säuerlicher
eigentlich macht ihr noch gerne einfach auch
meinen Salat noch mal so als grünen Abschluss
aber wenn ihr eure Dressing vorbereitet
könnt ihr das da schon direkt mit reingeben
so dann verrühre ich das und so könnt ihr alle
Dressings die ich euch heute zeige auch tagelang
im Kühlschrank aufbewahren und dann eben immer
rausholen auf euer salädchen machen und genießen
Dressing Nummer 4 wir machen einen
Honig Kräuterdressing dafür nehmen wir
uns natürlich Honig jetzt kommt auch wieder der
Senf zum Einsatz den würde ich jetzt auch nicht
weglassen weil gerade der Macht mit dem Honig
eben dass das total stimmig ist wie gesagt man
schmeckt die nicht raus so lustig bei jedem Rezept
hier bin ich den Senf am besten und trotzdem sage
ich der passt aber irgendwie immer dazu so
da kommt jetzt noch Salz mit rein und Pfeffer
so und da dürften jetzt auch zwei Zutaten wiederum
nicht fehlen und zwar wieder gutes Olivenöl und
ein Schuss Essig noch mal für die feine Säure und
anschließend könnt ihr Kräuter nehmen alle die
ihr mögt ich schreibe euch das was ich nutze auf
jeden Fall wieder in die Infobox damit ihr falls
ihr möchtet das ganz genau nachmachen könnt und
dann wird alles verrührt und auch dieses Dressing
ist vor allem jetzt eben durch den Essig total
lange halt beim Kühlschrank also ihr könnt ihn
wirklich bis zu 5 Tage im Kühlschrank aufbewahren
und dann immer rausholen wenn ihr euch gerade
einen Salat macht und fast hätte ich schon wieder
mein Knoblauch vergessen der kommt jetzt auch noch
mit rein und dann haben wir es aber der Knoblauch
darf in meinen Augen ja auch nicht fehlen wenn ihr
sagt okay muss jetzt nicht sein ihr könntet
auch auf den Knoblauch verzichten aber ich
finde der macht den Geschmack komplett rund und
das ist eins meiner lieblingsdressings [Musik]
ja das war es von meinen vier Dressings ich gönne
mir jetzt diesen Salat und mal gucken was ich mir
noch so zum Mittagessen zaubere und ansonsten
wünsche ich euch viel Spaß beim ausprobieren
macht unbedingt nach und schreibt mir dann gerne
in die Kommentare welches Dressing ihr am besten
fandet und ihr könnt noch sehr sehr gerne
Kommentare im reinschreiben und Vorschläge
welche Top Vier Rezepte als nächstes kommen
sollen z.B Top 4 Marinaden hätte ich noch auf
Lager oder auch in die süße Richtung Top
Vier tortencremes also schreibt mir das
sehr gerne ich gönne mir jetzt noch den Salat
und sage bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss [Musik]